hey this is preshtalwalker
triangle abc has sides of 8 7 and 9.
extend side a b and extend side ac
and then construct a circle o
that is tangent to the extended line
through a b the extended line through ac
and the line segment bc
this is tangent at the points m d and n
the question is what is the radius of
circle o i thank amit from india for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i posted this problem on twitter and i
want to give a huge thanks to everyone
who provided useful comments
these were part of the basis for the
solutions i'm presenting
thank you and if you want to read the
entire thread on twitter
give it a look i've also provided a link
in the video description
i will present two ways to solve the
problem
one method involves geometry and the
other involves trigonometry
let's get started with geometry
first suppose that bd has a length equal
to x
then dc will have a length that's equal
to 7 minus x
bm
and bd are congruent because they are
both external tangents to the circle
therefore bm is equal to x
similarly cn and cd have the same length
so cn has length 7 minus x
from here
a n is an external tangent that will be
congruent to a m
so we have 8 plus x is equal to sixteen
minus x
this means two x is equal to eight
so that x is equal to four
substitute in x is equal to four
this means b d and b m are equal to four
then
d c and c n are equal to seven minus x
which means each of them is equal to
three
next construct some line segments
construct the radii omnod
each of these has length equal to r
each of these radii is also
perpendicular to the line that's tangent
to them
then construct oc
ob and finally oa
we will now take a look at the area of
some shapes
let's get rid of the circle
now consider the entire quadrilateral a
n o m
its area will be equal to the area of
two right triangles it'll be a and o
plus a m o
but we can also calculate the area in
another way
the area this quadrilateral will also be
equal to the area of triangle abc
plus the area of triangle cno plus the
area of triangle cdl plus the area of
triangle bdo plus the area of triangle
[ __ ]
so we add up all these areas
so we have two different ways of
expressing the same area therefore
they're equal to each other
let's now calculate each of these areas
the area of triangle a n o
is equal to 12 r over two
that will be the same area for the
triangle amo
we add these areas together
and we get an area that's equal to 12r
now let's calculate the areas of some of
these other triangles
the area of triangle cno is equal to 3r
over 2. that's the same for the area of
triangle cdl
we add these two areas together to get a
total of 3r
then the area of triangle bdo is the
same of the area of triangle [ __ ]
and each of these has an area equal to
four r over two
so in total their areas are equal to
four r
the total of all of these areas is equal
to seven r
so we substitute that into the equation
so if 12r is equal to the area of
triangle abc plus 7r
so what's the area of triangle abc
we can solve for its area using heron's
formula
we first calculate the semi perimeter
and then we substitute into the formula
this is a straightforward calculation
we simplify under the radical to get the
area of triangle abc is equal to 12
multiplied by the square root of 5.
so we substitute that into the equation
then we subtract 7r from both sides to
get 5r is equal to 12 times the square
root of 5 which means r is equal to 12
times the square root of 5 all over 5
which is approximately equal to 5.367
and that's one way to solve this problem
let's now solve the problem using
trigonometry
we'll start from this part of the
derivation
we will again construct the following
line segment ao
this will divide angle a into two equal
angles equal to theta
from here we will consider triangle abc
to solve for the angle 2 theta
to do that we will use alkashi's law of
cosines
we have bc squared is equal to a b
squared plus ac squared minus 2
multiplied by a b multiplied by ac times
the cosine of 2 theta
we substitute in the values and then
solve for the cosine of 2 theta
this will be equal to two over three
we'll put that to the side for a second
and now let's consider the right
triangle a n o
in this right triangle
we have that r
is equal
to a n multiplied by the tangent of
theta
we don't know the tangent of theta so
we'll use the tangent half angle formula
and we'll use the form that involves the
cosine of two theta
we also know that the tangent here will
be positive because we have a positive
radius so we just take the positive
square root
so a n is equal to 12 and we've
substituted in the tangent half angle
formula
we know that the cosine of 2 theta is
equal to 2 over 3
so we then simplify
and this gives that r is equal to 12
divided by the square root of 5 which is
approximately equal to 5.367
and that's another way to solve the
problem
what an interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time